good morning good morning and welcome
class of 20 19 family members colleagues
sharing the stage with me to our
entering students I hope this is the
most exciting day of your lives so far
add to the parents and other family
members joining us today I hope this day
is your proudest so far toward the end
of june i began to consider this address
and I was meditating on what I might say
about the joys and challenges that Yale
will inevitably produce for you without
warning I found myself shocked by events
in which I had not participated and over
which I had no control this happens more
often than you would think in the weeks
that followed Dean Holloway and I
realized that we could and should bring
before you a quite particular aspect of
the yale college experience both because
we want to open a campus conversation
about it and because we saw no better
time than now for you to begin using
your intellectual capacity to address
complex and substantive issues that
concern an entire community like
everyone else here I was confronted
earlier this summer by a horrifying
horrifying massacre in a Charleston
South Carolina church house of worship
founded nearly 200 years ago by slaves
praying for their freedom on a warm
summer evening nine african americans
were gunned down by a 21 year old white
man
with a history of renting in public
about white supremacy a man whom an hour
earlier the congregants had welcomed
into their Bible study that evening the
killer participated in prayer and
discussion and then he stood up argued
about scripture made racist statements
removed a 45 caliber handgun from his
backpack and began shooting at others in
the room he reloaded his gun five times
and fired dozens of shots he also
appears to have posted a vile manifesto
on the internet along with photographs
of himself posing with the Confederate
battle flag in the days that followed
the nation heard Barack Obama deliver a
eulogy that could rank as one of the
most powerful addresses of his
presidency many of us wept as we
listened to family members family
members of the victims forgive the
deranged killer of their loved ones and
we saw the people of South Carolina
consumed with an examination of how
signs and symbols of the Confederate
past had abruptly and inescapably become
questions about the present widespread
public discussion resulted in the
removal of a Confederate battle flag
that had long flown over the State
Capitol similar discussions began
regarding a battle flag incorporated
into the Alabama state seal the use of
the battle flag in everything from rock
concerts to street parades and the
status of various other memorials and
symbols of the Old South but what does
this have to do with Yale and with you
and me well as the events in South
Carolina shook the nation many members
of our own community
could not avoid considering a matter
that ties us here in New Haven to
similar questions of history naming
symbols and narrative our residential
colleges at Yale into which you are
being inducted this weekend constitute
one of our most cherished means of
fostering an unusually close sense of
community among undergraduates about one
in 12 of you has been assigned to
Calhoun college named when the college
system was instituted in the 1930s for
jhansi Calhoun a graduate of Yale in the
class of 1804 he achieved extremely high
prominence in the 19th century as a
notable political theorist a vice
president to two different US presidents
a secretary of war and of state and a
congressman incentive senator
representing South Carolina Calhoun died
a decade before the outbreak of the
american civil war and so he did not
take place take part directly in the
politics of secession and the breakup of
the original Union however historians
have long recognized that the
secessionists of the time rested much of
their thinking on Calhoun's political
theory of nullification moreover and
what is more relevant to the concerns of
the moment Calhoun mounted the most
powerful and influential defense of his
day for slavery in fact he believed that
the highest forms of civilization depend
on involuntary servitude not only that
but he also believed that the races he
thought to be inferior black people in
particular ought to be subjected to it
for the sake of their own best interests
I'm not exaggerating in a famous speech
on the floor of the United States Senate
in 1837 Calhoun said I hold that in the
present state of civilization where two
races of different origin and
distinguished by color and other
physical differences as well as
intellectual are brought together the
relation now existing in the
slaveholding states between the two is
instead of an evil a paw a good a
positive good a year later in another
Senate speech he noted many in the South
once believed that slavery was a moral
and political evil that folly and
delusion are gone we see it now in its
true light and regarded as the most safe
and stable basis for free institutions
in the world moreover Calhoun never
wavered in these views considering his
life a few years before he died he wrote
in looking back I see nothing to regret
and little to correct so it was not
surprising that within a short time of
the massacre and subsequent debate in
South Carolina we found that the issues
of honoring naming and remembering that
have occasionally surfaced regarding
Calhoun College returned to challenge us
again the Yale Daily News launched a
forum that has drawn in passion comments
on all sides alumni and faculty have
written to me and to Dean Holloway from
varying perspectives summit length and
with considerable force and inevitably
we found ourselves wondering and not for
the first time how best to address the
undeniable challenges associated
with the fact that Calhoun's name graces
a residential community in Yale College
an institution where above all we prize
both the spirit and reality of full
inclusion so in the in the first moment
of hearing all this and in light of the
tragedy in South Carolina this summer
you might be wondering what the
challenge here might be why not simply
hold a meeting of the relevant
authorities and decide to rename Calvin
College thereby sending a clear message
that Yale definitively rejects this
association with the past history of
white supremacy and slavery and those
who attempt to justify it jhansi Calhoun
in particular things are rarely so
simple you the freshman starting Yale
today have arrived at a college that has
held a central place in American history
for over 300 years Dean Holloway will
soon illustrate for you in his remarks
that yells ties to the past are
complicated and sometimes surprising
they are also entangled with virtually
every moral and political controversy
the United States has encountered in its
history since well before the former
colonies became a nation our buildings
and programs echo with the names of
individuals greater and lesser who
played their part in these controversies
so we must be wary about ways in which
we might seek to alter markers of the
past for the sake of present purposes we
should consider the dangers for instance
of judging past figures according to
views and standards that evolved and
developed after their own times we also
must consider what it means to attempt
to a face or distance ourselves
from our own history some have sought to
control our thinking about the past by
selectively wiping away its traces
eliminating or softening it's
inconvenient or unflattering or
dangerous elements are we better off
perhaps retaining before us the name and
evocative sometimes brooding presence of
Yale graduate Jonesy Calhoun he may
serve to remind us not only of yells
complicated and occasional and
occasionally painful associations with
the past but to enforce in us a sense of
our own moral FAL ability as we
ourselves faced questions about the
future we will also be reminded to
consider the fact that generations of
Yale students have recreated Calhoun
College in their own images just as you
will in your own colleges and these
alumni associate its name not with a
remote historical figure but instead
with a beloved place a place where they
learned to live to love to think and to
imagine I don't believe that I have the
answer to the question of whether we
should rename Calhoun college however
I'm standing before you raising these
considerations because I do have a
strong mind about two things the first
is that catalyzed by this summer's
events in Charleston and the particulars
of Jhansi Calhoun's life and beliefs the
time has come for us to have a
thoughtful and public discussion of what
we ought to do the second is that
everyone connected to Yale will have
something to contribute to the
discussion whether faculty staff
students or alumni
whether historian or philosopher or
psychologist and whether one initially
sees the issue as central or peripheral
to the way we understand ourselves as a
community but let me be clear with you
about what I am proposing on what I'm
not proposing I cherish yells traditions
and her history and I do not believe we
should undo them motivated solely by
events or emotions of the moment I'm
either championing changing the name of
Calhoun but nor am i arguing for
retaining the status quo the issue is
complex and you will see that there are
substantive arguments on both sides good
people moral principle people can and
will disagree about it I am suggesting
rather that we should give careful
consideration to what criteria we could
and should use to change the
institutional names and Association we
have with some his particular historical
figure while in the process avoiding
renaming exercises to alleviate an
entire range of historical grievances or
current discomforts that is I'm not
suggesting that we should reconsider
just any name or the use of any symbol
that some find offensive as you know
there'd be no end to that process but of
course jhansi Calhoun is not just any
historical figure nor is the name of
Calhoun College just any name so I'm
asking the Yale community in all its
parts to engage on this matter with the
kind of reflective thorough and civil
consideration that I believe it clearly
deserves without denying free expression
to any opinion or to any form of
communication I'm also happy to express
my view
which I hope is widely shared that we
can best conduct this conversation in
ways that go beyond competing petitions
or protests anonymous blogging or social
media intimidation we should pursue
instead the kind of rational open
discourse that characterizes an
intellectual community committed to
looks at where we toss to light and
truth if this kind of conversation
cannot or does not happen on the
campuses of the nation's colleges and
universities that we should be concerned
whether it can happen anywhere and
freshman of the class of twenty nineteen
well you are very new here both excited
and anxious purposeful and confused and
thinking most immediately about setting
up your rooms taking language exams and
finding your way around campus why do we
engage you in this issue it's very
simple you've come to a place that
matters in the world of ideas and for
the rest of your lives you will be using
ideas to wrestle with difficult
many-sided questions members of the
class of twenty nineteen here is your
first hard problem welcome PL
in a moment one of yells principal
scholars of the african-american
experience the author of a distinctive
memoir on the era of Jim Crow but also
in not incidentally the former master of
Calhoun college itself your Dean
Jonathan Holloway will begin our
institutional process of reflection I
take as my final words today a part of
what President Abraham Lincoln said at
the battlefield near Gettysburg the
world will little note no long remember
what we say here but it can never forget
what they did here it is for us the
living rather to be dedicated here to
the unfinished work which they who
fought here have thus far so nobly
advanced it is rather for us to be here
dedicated to the great task remaining
before us that from these honored dead
we take increased devotion to that cause
for which they gave the last full
measure of devotion that we here highly
resolve that these dead shall not have
died in vain in using phrases such as
the unfinished work and the great task
remaining before us Lincoln reminds us
that we always have more to do as an
institution of higher education what are
our obligations with respect to how we
represent ourselves to the world and to
each other by virtue of whom we choose
to honor and remember what things
contribute to or detract from the
accurate remembering of the past and
contribute to or detract from our
ability to think wisely about the future
as entering yell students of the class
of twenty nineteen what are your
obligations to rest from this place and
education that encourages you to
question tradition even while honoring
it to chart your own history even while
learning from the past to enter fully
into difficult conversations even while
respecting contradictory ideas and
opinions I know in the next four years
you will make progress on figuring this
all out let's get started today let's
get started together welcome class
you
you
provas Pollock Dean Cooley Dean Gendler
secretary golf crews chaplain Coogler
masters deans and honored guests
allowing me to join President Saleh day
and wishing you a good morning and
welcome class of 2019 I'm thrilled to
see you here and look forward to getting
to know you well in the years ahead
together we will add a new chapter to
Yale's narrative it'll be a chapter
filled with astonishing highs intense
disagreements controversy laughter and I
hope an enduring sense of community to
the parents siblings aunts uncles and
grandparents who have done such critical
work shaping and raising the students
seated before us thank you you have a
lot for which to be proud this morning
to the students seated before us I
presume that you have thanked your
family numerous times for the sacrifices
that have brought you here if not I
expect you to correct that oversight
immediately following the assembly in
addition to recognizing your family's
contributions I implore every student to
take a few minutes today to reach out to
someone from your respective hometowns
just as Yale coaches professors
administrators custodians conductors
dining hall workers librarians and
groundskeepers will do everything they
can to help you succeed there are
legions of similar people from your
communities who have assisted you in
your journey here thank them I recognize
that each of you has taken an individual
paths to this place but now that you are
here you have a group identity as well
you are the class of twenty nineteen
after all but who exactly are you you
hail from across this country and from
around the world many of you are
children of parents who are who are
already Yale alumni
more of you will be the first in your
families to graduate from college at all
most of you went to public school nearly
half of you are receiving financial aid
all of you are dazzling these facts are
part of your collective narrative at
this the very first page of your Yale
story but what of this place the place
that claims you as its own in hopes that
you in time will return the favor what
is yells narrative I won't bother going
into much present-day detail I feel safe
in my assumption that you've read the
brochures and web pages and that you may
even already track our mascot handsome
Dan on Instagram but being here by being
here you signal that some part of you
has already accepted Yale's narrative
about pursuing excellence about mental
discipline about valuing diversity and
about light and truth and honestly I
believe that narrative is accurate and
that this place is as dazzling as each
of you but has it always been this way
as a historian I'm predisposed to ask if
and how things have changed over time so
I wonder what does yells narrative look
like when we explore its past for the
next few minutes of like for you to turn
to the images that are in your program a
close reading of these images what we
historians call primary sources will
help us reflect upon this place and its
history the image you see images you see
are something of a triptych three
different paintings of British merchant
Elihu Yale that when brought together
tell a fascinating story for those who
don't already know Elihu Yale rose to
power and accumulated wealth to his
leadership in the East India Company in
1718 Yale received a request to finance
a new building for the Collegiate School
of Connecticut a small Enterprise
founded in 1701 for the training of
Congregationalist ministers Yale sent
hundreds of books a portrait of King
George the first and bales of goods that
were later sold to finance the building
in short order the
allegiant school was renamed in his
honor I known as an aside that LSU Yale
made that donation because of the
effective lobbying of a colonial author
named Jeremiah dumber what this means is
that you probably should not be called
Yale ease at all but rather dummies but
this is a historical problem for another
day as far as we know there aren't that
many paintings of Elihu Yale and for
understandable reasons yale university
has many if not all of them you have in
your hand three examples of this
collection of Elihu Liana as you see
Elihu Yale figures centrally in all
three images in the first Elihu Yale is
by himself below that you find him
depicted with the servant and in the
reverse you see him surrounded by
similar men of high standing with a
young page to their collective left in
all of the paintings Elihu Yale is
wearing and surrounded by sumptuous
fabrics this tells us that he is a man
of means in the two paintings on side
one we see ships in the distance a
reference to the fact that Elihu Yale
built his career on trade that navigated
the ports in the british empire in the
second and third paintings we see an
unidentified attendant much like the
wearing of exquisite clothes suggested
placing a servant in a portrait was an
articulation of standing and wealth but
when we look more carefully at these two
paintings we notice that in addition to
the fine clothes the servant and page
are wearing they also happen to have
metal collars and clasps around their
necks what we are seeing in each
painting then isn't a servant or a page
but a slave we are fairly certain that
Elihu Yale did not own any slaves
himself but there's no doubting the fact
that he participated in the slave trade
profiting from the sale of human beings
just as he profited from the sale of so
many actual objects that were part of
the East India trade empire as such
Elihu Gail's wealth was linked to a
global economy
that was deeply practically inextricably
interwoven with the sale of human beings
to other human beings in fact when we
look at the paintings it is safe to
assume that Elihu Yale was a willing
participant in that economy since he
could have selected anything to
represent him in these paintings we can
conclude that he chose to be depicted
with enslaved people because he believed
this narrative would best signify his
wealth power and worldliness this is a
difficult story to hear especially on an
occasion of welcoming and celebration
but I share it with you because just as
proper histories are unafraid of their
darker corners you should be unafraid to
ask difficult questions of this
University indeed we expect you to do so
I also share this store because
historians understand that the people
places and things about which we write
leave legacies that connect the past to
the present and often unsettling ways by
means of example that's returned to the
paintings their story does not stop in
the 18th century when they were created
this fact is confirmed when we consider
how this group of portraits has been put
to use by the University two are in
storage along with the bulk of Yale's
vast collections but one is on display
the first of your three images hangs in
the corporation room of Woodbridge Hall
the nerve center of the University that
this specific portrait hangs there
however is fairly recent history until
2007 the second painting of Elihu Yale
you see in your program insert is what
you would have found in the corporation
room that year recognizing that this
representation was terribly jarring
whether it was understood in its
historical context or not the university
removed the painting there was no
ceremony accompanying this move no
conversation just a quiet exchange of
one portrait for another was this the
right thing to do was this a missed
opportunity to opportunity to ask larger
questions about race representations
economic systems and specifically Empire
to both questions I answer a singular
perhaps I believe the painting was taken
down with the best of intentions but I'm
left still with more questions questions
not just about the portraits but about
also but also about many of the symbols
names and legacies that surround us on
the campus many of which may have been
instituted with good intentions who
doesn't do what they think is best but
that now clashed discordantly with our
values and aspirations of course
addressing addressing questions of
intention legacy and belonging is not
merely a local challenge consider the
recent struggles over the Confederate
flag and who belongs in the
twenty-dollar bill consider the pointed
language about who is legally in this
country or not but addressing these
questions also remains a decidedly local
challenge consider the new and ongoing
debate about the title of master which
we use for the heads of our residential
colleges these clashes between the
history we inherit and the future we
aspire to create our common at Yale as
they are across the United States to be
a Yalie is to be an engaged citizen of
the University and the world so these
are questions that we need to think
through together what should we do with
the artifacts of a past that now offends
us do we leave them in view to haunt us
if we erase portions of who we are
hiding them from view without engaging
them do we run the risk of
self-satisfaction if we are prepared to
change the name of one college say
Calhoun because John Calhoun's anti
abolitionism what are we to do with
those named for individuals who also
owned slaves were deeply racist or whose
personal views on any number of issues
run counter to our current sensibilities
to be clear I am not advocating that we
change the name of this university that
much is off the table but these
questions lead us to even more questions
is it possible to simultaneously hold
conflicting feelings about a thing and
its history can we love Yale College and
quarrel with the man who gave this place
its name
inevitably honest and informed debate
will yield a range of possibilities
about the right way forward I am certain
that my answers may not be the same as
many of yours how should we reconcile
them and ourselves as you answer these
questions you will do well to remember
that the Yale community which you have
just joined looks radically different in
ways that would have been beyond the
imagination of the 18 year old men who
in 1965 sat in the same seats you
occupied today similarly the yellow 2065
will be something quite distinct from
what your present collective imagination
can summon this place is ever evolving
and this is how it should be at a great
University to do or be otherwise to
remain wet only to tradition and
incurious determination to keep things
the way they are just because would mean
that we have defaulted on our commitment
to ask penetrating potentially
destabilizing questions of our known
worlds so class of 2019 here you are in
a place that has been waiting a long
time for you to arrive a place where you
emphatically belong whatever your race
religion wealth sport political
philosophy taste in music whatever your
sexuality your passports origin or the
number of stamps in your passport this
place is yours ready for you to make
your contribution to it you have come
here to unique moment when this
university engages with questions of its
own identity at a time when national
conversations about race have shined a
light on social constructions and
assumptions that for many but not for
all have lain dormant for decades if not
centuries you also bring your own
questions about your own identities and
what the future holds for you these big
questions will form part of the
education that awaits you even more than
problem sets term papers or exams but so
will the
that begins today as you write your own
story and build your own Yale this is
hard but joyous work and you embark on
it with many others joining you are your
peers and your professors the friends
you are about to make and the students
who have preceded you I join you too
welcome to this work welcome to this
place welcome to Yale
Oh
Oh
my beloved Yale family as we ready
ourselves to step out onto new ground in
this daunting yet inspiring liminal
space of the unknown next we begin a
poignant turn of goodbyes and hellos
that invite laughter tears discovery and
pride let us go forth with deep trust in
certain knowledge that love surrounds us
that beauty can surprise us that light
and truth awaits us on this day and
evermore may all that is holy shine upon
us and tenderly bless our every breath
may we go in Shalom in Salaam in Shanti
may we go in peace let us begin